this video supported by our friends over
at cheddar hey wisecrack jared here
unless you're living in a galaxy far far
away you've probably heard about the
recent Star Wars backlash some fans
hated last Jedi so much they issued an
anti Disney manifesto run an actress off
Instagram our crowdfunding for a remake
and have claimed credit for solos
failure at the box office there were
even rumors that Kathleen Kennedy be
president of Lucas Films would retire
early possibly influenced by Twitter
this may seem like a bunch of fanboys
throwing tantrums or Russian BOTS and
while both of those may be partly true I
can't help but think there's something
way deeper going on here so join us as
we try to use philosophy to explain the
current crisis of the Star Wars universe
and some minor last Jedi spoilers ahead
also for any of our fans that live in LA
we're gonna be hosting a live Halloween
show on October 26 with our movie
podcast crew and Adam Kovac from
funhouse so check out the invite and the
link to tickets in the description but
first a quick recap of what people hate
about the new Star Wars while there's
some rather unpleasant threads of
criticism on the Internet some people
hate the new Star Wars for a reason that
director Rian Johnson is pretty overt
about subverting the Canon or as he
likes to call it killing the past Rey's
parents aren't Skywalker's or Kenobi's
or some other great family but nobody's
despite the constant mystery box teasing
in the force awakens we get no storied
rise of Snoke or reveal that he's maced
Windu or something just an unceremonious
death and then there's Luke we're
supposed to believe this wholesome hero
who once saw the light in the darkest of
villains is now throwing lightsabers off
cliffs and almost killing his child
nephew that just didn't seem right with
Disney now putting all of their extended
universe movies on hold and new Star
Wars spin-offs getting universe
and by fans it seems like the world of
Star Wars is in crisis what's happening
with Star Wars is not so different from
a problem often faced by social systems
or what political philosopher Jurgen
Habermas calls the legitimation crisis
ie an existential crisis that threatens
the foundation of a social system social
systems are made of three sub parts the
governmental the socio-cultural and the
economic they all interact and in some
ways these three systems map onto the
system of Star Wars fandom let's start
with the government side see the system
needs some kind of story or idea to give
it legitimacy governments do this
through different means monarchies claim
their legitimacy is derived from God
democracies through election by the
people constitutional governments
through well constitutions even
dictators claim legitimacy in one way or
another some by claiming they represent
the will of the people
other things help to making sure your
citizens are warm and fed or the
economic it does wonders to make them
ask fewer questions about how or why
you're allowed to be in power so what
happens when this is called into
question what happens when the people no
longer feel a system is upholding its
values or that those values are
antiquated and useless what if people
feel betrayed when a huge corporation
takes over their beloved franchise only
to birth what some consider to be an
unholy abomination when this happens
people stop obeying and start rebelling
think about countries whose populations
take to the streets when they suspect
that their new leaders rigged the
election and therefore aren't legitimate
if we use this as a metaphor for star
wars a lot of things start to make sense
lucas was basically the divinely
ordained monarch of the star wars
universe which consisted not just of his
six films he made but also a ton of
spin-offs in the form of video games
board games cartoons and tie-in novels
that got the Royal Seal of Approval from
Lucasfilm so maybe it's more like a
constitutional monarchy but his
legitimacy also came from the fact that
he you know created it all together with
Lucas Star Wars fans helped create a
fully functioning social system with
shared practices beliefs values and
agreed upon rules of operation that's
what harbor mas might call a
socio-cultural side of this system
Habermas calls this kind of socially
cohesive
Levens death a life world and the Jedi
could Levens veldt with the best of them
the general meaning of Star Wars the
values it represents the characters it
has developed the stories it tells and
the themes that define it were
originally laid out by Lucas and were
more or less agreed upon within the
community okay
maybe you hate Jar Jar but you got over
it Lucas's word was still Star Wars law
even if you didn't exactly like it they
need a midi-chlorian code like all life
worlds this Star Wars universe also
helped create a sense of individual
identity when people use these values
and beliefs to make meaning of their
lives
that is until 2012 when disney bought
lucas films and started to get crazy i
guess you could say there's been a
regime change and suddenly at least from
the perspective of some fans lord lucas
was replaced by a money-hungry animated
Mouse it's like the governmental
equivalent of Queen Elizabeth relinquish
the throne and after a nice bribe
pending the British monarchy to marry
Barry after Disney gained rights to all
Star Wars intellectual property and
started making controversial decisions
they found themselves in a big old
legitimation crisis what the fanbase is
going through can perhaps be best
understood by looking at one of the
biggest legitimation crises of the last
millennia one that changed the landscape
of the entire world
you say Disney is facing the same kind
of legitimation crisis the Catholic
Church did in the 1500s when their
congregations began to rebel up until
the 16th century the leadership of the
Catholic Church had total control over
the meaning of the Bible since only
priests bishops the Pope and maybe the
occasional rich guy had access to hard
copies books including the Bible were so
expensive that very few ever learned to
read this famously allowed the church to
get away with some seriously shady Sh
like making people pay the church in the
form of indulgences to get their loved
ones out of purgatory but all that
changed when good old Johnny Gutenberg
invented the printing press in 1440 and
enabled the rapid reproduction of texts
suddenly regular people could read the
Bible and what do you know
they had slightly different
interpretations of some of those crucial
texts in this case a crisis of
legitimation happened because the masses
were no longer merely consuming
religious meaning but also helping
produce canonical interpretations the
legitimacy and authority of the Catholic
Church was seriously thrown into
question by people like Martin Luther
who posted ninety-five reasons why the
Catholic Church sucked right on their
door this crisis of legitimation and the
proliferation of different kinds of
Christianity really sucked for Europe as
competing factions really really liked
murdering each other so in this metaphor
the Bible is the original Star Wars
universe and why did George Lucas get to
interpret it however he wanted because
he wrote it maybe he's not Jesus in this
analogy but he's at least an apostle or
a prophet but now the authority has
moved from a single divinely inspired
leader to a larger infallible
organization and people question why
they wield authority in developing quasi
holy texts or it's canon and the recent
films but especially with the last Jedi
they changed many of the agreed-upon
values meanings and troops of the Star
Wars system if there was just a change
of hands from Lucas to Disney with the
quote administration of Star Wars
remaining mostly the same people may not
have asked questions but without the
legitimacy of Lucas people started
asking more questions and Disney didn't
stop there they also put the very
identity of the community when they took
a super laser to the Canon de canonizing
radio dramas video games comics and
hundreds of spin-off novels that
Lucasfilm previously considered part of
the gospel remember that a life world is
important because it defines a community
by clarifying who's in and out and who
you can trust you can't just go around
hacking and slashing what counts the
Star Wars because people's identities
are wrapped up in mission Star Wars
enthusiasts aren't just consumers of
this Canon they've helped make the
meaning of the Star Wars universe like
the Catholic Church Disney now faces the
wrath of the educated masses except now
the problem isn't just that people can
read they blog to eat make video essays
produce their own cartoons and stream
content to millions of viewers and for
every Martin Luther there are a million
angry youtubers and vloggers each
posting their own 95 problems with
Disney star wars we live in an age where
people aren't just consuming media but
are also producing it where prosumers
and if Protestantism emerged with the
printing press and literacy took the
interpretive power away from the dudes
the funny hats it seems like the age of
the prosumer empowers people to
criticize the few anointed successors of
lukas now prosumer i know it sounds like
we made that word up but it's actually a
technical term coined in the 1980s by
futurist Alvin and Heidi Toffler to
describe how the role of the producer
and consumer will merge in the age of
modern technology Star Wars fans are
basically prosumers extraordinaire
everyday fans have played a huge role in
creating meaning of Star Wars by sharing
YouTube videos posting video essays or
fan theories subscribing to our slash
Empire did nothing wrong or retweeting
Lord Palpatine in the age of prosumer
ISM every theory about where Luke was
all this time who's Snoke is which Jedi
uses which lightsaber fighting styles is
one way of contributing to the Star Wars
universe it's a way for the community to
practice Star Wars now imagine if you
engage in your religious tradition in
your community and all the sudden the
recently appointed Church authority
tells you you're doing it all wrong the
wafers are a lie
and while Star Wars may be the latest it
isn't the only franchise open to
legitimation crises within their
communities prosumer ism is beginning to
affect the relations between fans and
producers even scaring away james
mangold director of logan who recently
tweeted at the point when work writing
and directing big franchises has become
the emotionally loaded equivalent of
writing a new chapter of the Bible with
the probable danger of being stoned and
called a blasphemer then a lot of bolder
minds are gonna leave these films to
hacks and corporate boards so is the
Star Wars system about to collapse under
the weight of its crisis not necessarily
the Catholic Church obviously didn't
crumble under their legitimation hiccup
and maybe Star Wars won't either because
the thing is systems learn after a few
Vatican councils and papal deaths the
Catholic Church managed to revise some
of the violent theology and
re-solidified the community under common
goals and shared beliefs sure there were
Protestants who totally pieced out and
started their own thing but in general
the system learned adjusted and stayed
intact so the question is which
direction will the Star Wars system take
will Disney find a way to evolve in the
time of prosumer ISM respecting their
fans in the universe they've helped
create well fans choose to grow with the
system and find new ways of interacting
with their beloved
or will there be a reckoning where
Disney in the fans part ways like the
Catholics and Protestants each starting
their own version of the religion and
competing for the souls of viewers let
us know what you guys think and if you
enjoyed our take on the star wars crisis
and I highly recommend checking out our
friends over at shedder they recently
launched their own YouTube channel and
are cranking out awesome videos that
cover business tech media and news
without the boring parts from the inside
scoop on the latest news stories -
detailed answers for even the most
ambiguous questions cheddar has got you
covered
cheddar also produces videos that
examine the triumphs and failures of the
media we enjoy so I just watched their
video on how bankrupt Marvel risked its
main characters to save itself and
suggest you guys check it out - so they
give you an inside look at how Marvel
went from filing bankruptcy in 1996 to
making James Cameron quiver on his
throne of shattered box-office records
so watch the video and perhaps you'll
find a new hope that Disney can redeem
the beloved Star Wars franchise and if
you like it consider subscribing to
their channel just click here or the
link below for more videos from cheddar
and as always guys thanks for watching
peace
[Music]